machine learning is everywhere you look
and it's made of put different pieces
when building a model you may not be
thinking about the infrastructure needed
to train and serve it and that's why
coop flow exists let's talk about what
queue flow is trying to solve and how
you can use it
[Applause]
welcome to cube lo 101 today we'll be
giving an introduction to keep flow if
you want to check out the documentation
directly check out the link below to
read more about cube flow now when it
comes to maintaining machine learning
systems it can be especially challenging
to manage all the application platform
and resource considerations ml apps have
a different footprint from other web or
mobile deployments for example a
training phase is resource intensive
while an inference phase is lightweight
and speedy you'll also need the tools
and frameworks to run all of these
pieces existing solutions that are great
for building applications and other
domains don't capture the nuances needed
4 ml so key flow is all about creating a
standard for deploying enterprise ml
apps not just development or production
but the entire lifecycle cube flow is an
open source project that contains a
curated set of compatible tools and
frameworks specific for ml one of the
primary goals for cube flow is to make
it easy for everyone to develop deploy
and manage portable scaleable machine
learning it may not surprise you to hear
it's built on top of kubernetes an open
source platform for running and
orchestrating containers kubernetes is
built to run consistently across
different environments and this is key
to how key flow operates let's talk
about three principles that keep low is
built around composability Portability
and scalability composability means that
you can choose what's right for you on
your project people starting out in
machine learning tend to be focused on
the end result of the model but there's
more than just building a model the
process that goes into an ml project has
many stages and each stage is made up of
different building blocks that you
choose it shouldn't matter if you have
special requirements for your ml
workflow like if you need to use
different versions of tensorflow
for different parts of your project cube
flow extends kubernetes ability to run
independent and configurable steps with
machine learning specific frameworks and
libraries portability means you can run
all the pieces of your
project anywhere you're running cute
loom so it handles the platform
specifics and you can just focus on your
model write your code once and let Q
Blow handle the abstraction so you can
run it on your laptop and on-prem
training rig and in the cloud
scalability means your projects can
access more resources when they're
needed and release them when they're not
every environment can have different
computing resources like CPUs GPUs and
TP use but you may also need to scale
across teams and running experiments q
flow leverages the abilities built into
kubernetes to maximize available
resources and scale with as little
manual effort as possible so if you're
familiar with kubernetes you can
probably see how it enables cube flow to
do all of these but there's also a lot
of complexity in knowing how kubernetes
works which can require expertise and
many additional concepts another option
may be hosted mo offerings but that may
not work if you have on-prem hardware
requirements q flow is designed to let
kubernetes do what it's good at and
allow you to focus on defining and
running ML workflows including managing
data running notebooks training models
and serving them it's also open source
and has a growing community now that's a
pretty high-level overview of what q
flow is in the next video we'll go
through setting it up and running an
example but you can also try it out for
yourself on google cloud by checking out
the link below and visiting q org to
read more
[Music]
[Applause]